hi there Steve Kaufman here I was asked
to do a video on pronunciation and
that's what I'm going to do but first
let me announce that we're going to
continue with our hangouts on Google+
and we're going to have one tomorrow
that's Thursday and it'll be at 4 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time that's here in
Vancouver or on the west coast of North
America which is midnight UTC which used
to be known as Greenwich Mean Time so we
don't expect any European participants
and on Saturday we're going to have one
at 8 a.m. Pacific Standard Time which is
4 p.m. or 1600 hours UTC or 5:00 in the
evening in the Central European Time
Germany France and that one is going to
be primarily in German primarily or
maybe entirely in German depending on
who shows up with regard to the one on
Thursday I don't know I think we have
someone from Turkey who lives in Sweden
we have a hope someone from Japan so
we'll see which languages are used there
and I'm going to be talking about the
recent changes to link and also language
learning in general now I had a request
again I'm very bad I get these requests
and then I forget the name of the person
but this is a gentleman from Russia who
is very pleased with the input based
approach to language learning he says
it's really helped him improve his
comprehension and his skills generally
and certainly he wrote a flawless letter
in English or you know message a YouTube
but he says what advice do I have for
getting closer to native like
pronunciation ok I am NOT a speech
therapist I have not taught people to
pronounce I remember once when I was 19
in Montreal I was hitchhiking and I met
another fellow hitchhiker who was a
recent immigrant from Italy and he
couldn't say small he would always
Malia's from southern italy and i tried
to get me to go small and he would
always go scissor mom so that was while
we were waiting to get a lift there by
the roadside I think I might have
invited them to my home and helped him
out whatever I can't remember wasn't
very successful what do I recommend for
pronunciation the first thing is listen
listening is the key in my opinion
listen a lot listen to a limited amount
of content over and over again listen to
content that you like listen to content
that has some rhythm some bite to it so
it's almost like music I mean you can't
listen to a radio newscast but you can
listen to a comedian or someone who's
got a little bit of rhythm in it so that
you can listen to it over and over again
even if you don't understand it all
you're catching that rhythm there was an
immigrant to mention this before an
immigrant to Toronto from China his name
was Jerry died and he was in his mid-20s
and he'd been in Canada for five years I
thought he was a native-born Canadian
that's how good his pronunciation was
his secret was he listened to one CD
like thousands of times maybe that works
but who's gonna do that I wouldn't do
that
but I know that listening to these young
Frank dialog dialogues comic dialogues
in Chinese was tremendously helpful for
me and getting the tones right in
Chinese so listening get the sounds in
your head you can't pronounce something
that you can't hear you can't hear the
range of sounds you have you're not
going to be successful in pronouncing it
in my view no matter what use you make
of the international phonetic phonetic
alphabet or diagrams of your palate and
tongue or these these machines that you
talk into and back come some kind of a
of us a graph showing your sound that
you compared to the native speaker none
of that is going to work unless you can
hear the sound so lots of listening also
forget your own writing system I think
Japanese people suffer because they have
this kana system which is a syllabary
each syllable has a symbol and so
therefore they can't say like you know
bridge it's bull DG you just got to have
syllables
similarly in English you know the
relationship between pronunciation and
how words are spelled is pretty you know
haphazard so you can't rely on how it's
written so people who see the word we
know word they want to say water because
always there and if it's bird they want
to say beard or something forget it
you have to listen and and you have to
know like when I was learning Russian
you know it's not spicy Bowl it's spicy
but even though it's written spasibo
that's how they pronounce it so you
forget the writing system do a lot of
listening some sounds are difficult but
generally speaking it's not the sounds
that cause the biggest problem i know
when i was learning chinese i had
trouble making a [ __ ] [ __ ] son [ __ ]
chief ah [ __ ] she and the c sound
there's a few of those the notorious
hurt sound in swedish like like whoo
it's very difficult to say there's
always gonna be a few of those and you
work on the th sound in english for some
people you know in french or any
language has the e sound yeah you go ooh
and then try to say e so who becomes we
do anyway there's a few sounds but
that's normally not the biggest problem
the bigger problem is the rhythm of the
language so when you listen and try to
catch the rhythm of the language how
where did the stresses fall and so it's
often very good to listen to a paragraph
as initially a sentence and then after
that a paragraph and then try to repeat
it and try to repeat it and even if you
can't pronounce every word try to get
the rhythm and so there you know
obviously the thing there is to listen
and repeat and also to hear yourself but
here I would suggest although I have no
proof of
that don't try to compare yourself to
the native speaker too early I think
there's some there's real benefit in not
hearing yourself too much and in
focusing on hearing the way the native
speaker
whichever native speaker you want to
imitate how they speak so focus on
getting the sounds into you uh noticing
making sure you notice you got a notice
that spicy ba and not spicy bull
you got a notice that it's word bird
heard third are all pronounced the same
in English
you've got to notice that I mean my
father for example who was born in
Czechoslovakia and lived in Canada for
you know from 51 to 80 30 years he spoke
excellent English but he was saved like
there's a province in Canada called Nova
Scotia Nova Scotia n OD a Scotia SC o t
I ate Nova Scotia that's how it's
pronounced in English but to him it was
Nova's Katya you know because he wasn't
going to give in like to him it should
be Scott here because that's the value
of those letters in Czech or rye a
German or whichever language so I think
he spoke more during the Japanese
football and so he wouldn't let go but
you've got to let go you got to notice
it's Nova Scotia and if you want to
speak you can hang on to Nova Scotia if
that's what you want to do that's fine
but if you want a sound like a native
you've got to let go notice how they say
it and then get used to saying it the
same way so I think that eventually you
want to do some listening group and then
recording yourself and comparing and to
really fine-tune it but the main thing
first of all is to listen mainly many
times and deliberately notice and get
those sounds into your brain divorced
from how you think it should be
pronounced based on your alphabet or
anything else one other thing when you
go through all of that make sure about
one thing though that when you speak you
don't worry about your pronunciation
because I have dealt with so many people
in English who speak excellent English
and have
obvious accents it doesn't matter it is
far more important to have sound command
of the language of vocabulary of phrases
to be able to express yourself to
indicate obviously that you understand
what the other person is saying all of
those things that have to do with
effective communication are much more
important than the pronunciation of
words I can remember I dealt with a
Swiss banker here and he had a sidekick
an assistant who was from England and
the Swiss banker spoke much better
English than the fellow from England his
use of words he was so precise and I
used the language wide vocabulary but he
had this way sucks and like that whereas
this English guy stumbled in his own
native language so it's just to say that
what really matters is how well you
express yourself overall and if you get
uptight about your accent if you think
people are judging you about your
pronunciation in fact you will be worse
everything in language and learning has
to do with relaxing feeling comfortable
feeling confident and just taking it for
granted that you are communicating
effectively people are happy to
communicate with you and that goes in
particular with pronunciation some
people are going to be better at
pronouncing than others and and maybe
that's another reason why I tend to
prefer when I'm learning language I
don't worry about pronunciation at the
beginning at all because what I found is
that people who I found that people
either begin pronouncing fairly well and
then improve a little bit over time or
they begin pronouncing very poorly and
never ever improve I mean I know people
who have lived in Canada for 30 40 50
years and speak English and their
pronunciation has never improved they
interact daily and they haven't improved
so I think it's worthwhile to make sure
you get enough of the language in you
that you're familiar with the sounds
that your brain more than you they
familiar the brain is used to these
sounds the brain recognizes the sounds
so that you know if you're pronouncing
it correctly
Klee or not so make sure you get a lot
of listening exposure and then you know
start doing some of these other things
like working on the rhythm you know
listening and repeating and then at some
point but not right at the beginning
listening repeating and recording
yourself and comparing so that you can
really fine-tune it but I wouldn't do
that at the beginning because you don't
want to reinforce any pronunciation
problems that you have at the beginning
if you let it go for a while after your
brain is more familiar with the sounds
you will probably do better so I don't
know if that's helpful I am sure there
are professional accent reduction people
who can give you better advice on
pronunciation but I was asked to do one
on pronunciation so there you have it
thanks for listening bye for now